You’ll often hear it claimed that lobsters
are biologically immortal.
So is it true?
Not really, though this is partially an argument
in semantics as you’ll soon see.
(And while we’re on the topic of lobster
myths, no: Lobsters do not mate for life.
In fact, the male lobster pretty much gets
it on with every female lobster that comes
a knockin’.
And they do almost literally line up and knock
on the male’s door.)
So what’s the source of the staple of social
media timelines that lobsters can’t die
of old age?
Cells make up all living creatures on Earth,
from humans to lobsters.
(Shocker, I know.)
However, cell replication is limited based
upon nucleotide sequences called telomeres
which are found on the ends of chromosomes.
In a nutshell, telomeres prevent the strands
of DNA from coming undone and also prevent
them from accidentally fusing with neighboring
chromosomes.
The issue is that these end caps get shorter
each time the cell divides owing to the fact
that the enzymes that duplicate the DNA, with
a little help from short pieces of RNA, cannot
do so all the way to the end of a chromosome.
So something gets cut off every time a replication
occurs.
Telomeres ensures that what is cutoff isn’t
critical information.
But the result of this shortening each time
is that telomeres eventually become too short
to provide an adequate buffer.
For reference, human cells can only be replicated
around forty to seventy times before the telomeres
become too short.
This leads to the cell no longer being able
to correctly replicate and to cell death.
Lobster cells work a little differently.
A lobster’s body produces quantities of
the enzyme telomerase even into adulthood.
While humans and other vertebrates also produce
telomerase, our bodies only (usually) produce
it while in embryonic form.
What does telomerase do?
It continuously repairs the cells’ telomeres,
keeping it from becoming too short.
The result is that the DNA in the cells can
continue to replicate indefinitely- hence
why it is often claimed that lobsters are
technically “immortal.”
Image Courtesy of the University of Utah Health
Sciences
While partially an argument in semantics,
the problem here is that when most hear “biologically
immortal,” they think it means that if a
lobster isn’t killed by some predator or
the like, lives in a suitable environment,
and has an adequate supply of nutrients to
supply their biological needs, the lobster
never gets old and can live forever.
But the truth is that there are many factors
that go into aging (a number of which aren’t
well understood), not just a cell’s ability
to replicate itself.
DNA damage happens over time regardless of
telomere length.
While much of this gets automatically repaired
via various mechanisms, genetic mutations
do occasionally occur from things such as
oxidative stress, potentially resulting in
cellular deterioration and malfunction.
With regards to the lobster, evidence at hand
appears to indicate they do, in fact, die
of what we’d colloquially call “old age”
eventually.
How?
Lots of ways, similar to humans.
For example, beyond potential environmental
damage to their cells causing issues, we know
definitively that how the lobster grows and
the metabolic energy required to do it greatly
affects their lifespan.
Humans grow through childhood and adolescence
until they reach a certain size after which
they usually do not grow any bigger (at least
not vertically…)
A lobster’s body, however, never stops growing.
Lobsters grow in size during a process called
molting, in which they shed their hard exoskeleton,
from claws to tail, before growing a new one
around a bigger body.
A young lobster may molt several dozen times
before its first birthday as it rapidly grows.
The process slows to about once a year by
around age seven and then once every two or
three years after that.
The largest lobster ever caught weighed in
at a whopping forty-four pounds.
For reference, a typical lobster you’ll
find in the store or restaurant usually rings
in at about 1-2 pounds and is around 5-10
years old.
The bigger a lobster, (usually) the greater
its age.
However, molting takes more and more energy
as a lobster increases in size and the amount
of effort it takes for even a 30-50 year old
lobster to molt kills between 10% and 15%
of the lobsters every year.
But just because lobsters can potentially
continue to grow and molt up until their death,
that does not mean they always do so, even
if they have sufficient food available and
ideal environmental conditions.
Elderly lobsters have been observed to stop
molting altogether, with the theory being
that their bodies simply no longer have the
capacity to do so, likely via a lack of the
needed metabolic energy.
Much like an elderly human is often more susceptible
to things like pneumonia for various age related
reasons, this is a major problem for the lobsters
as it often leads to shell disease, a bacterial
infection in the shell that can form scar
tissue between the lobster and the shell.
If they are able to molt again later, they
potentially have the problem of scar tissue
binding the inner body and the shell which
can cause the lobster to become stuck and
die.
Shell disease can also lead to other problems
such as shell rotting, with the net effect
being the same- the lobster that no longer
molts dies.
So how long do lobsters actually live before
dying of these types of so-called natural
causes?
This isn’t clear at all.
Estimating how old the largest lobsters ever
found are comes with a huge margin of error.
As Biologist Carl Wilson of the Maine Department
of Marine Resources explains, “The problem
with lobsters is when they molt, they molt
their entire exoskeleton, including their
digestive tract and gastric mill and the like,
so there are no hard parts that are left,”
leaving little in the way of accurately measurable
physical markers.
Even judging by size isn’t fool proof owing
to a variety of environmental factors greatly
influencing their rate of growth.
But for reference, using several different
means of trying to judge the age of lobsters,
the overarching average lifespan in the wild
of the various types of lobsters out there
is thought to be about thirty years for males
and around fifty or sixty years for females.
So if you want to use as the definition of
“biologically immortal”- “no known point
in which cells will stop replicating barring
outside influence,” then lobster are possibly
biologically immortal.
But even then, it should be noted that there
has never been a definitive study (to date)
demonstrating that lobsters producing telomerase
throughout their adulthood actually increases
their natural lifespan.
There is so much more that goes into real-life
biological immortality than just if the cells
have a point in which they will definitely
stop being able to replicate, and we humans
(unfortunately for all of us alive today)
don’t yet fully understand all the factors
at play nor exactly how much telomeres really
plays a causative role in aging.
If body and cellular aging only had to do
with telomeres, few humans would be colloquially
labeled to die of “old age” before around
the age of 120.
In the end, even with ample resources and
in an optimal environment, most lobsters’
bodies seem to cease to be able to sustain
themselves at around 1/3 to 2/3 the age an
average human lives before we succumb to our
own set of complications due to age related
factors.
So while it is a semantic argument, it seems
a bit of a stretch to call lobsters biologically
immortal just because their cells don’t
see telomeres shortening like many other animals.
Humans have shorter telomeres than mice, but
mice die of “old age” after only a few
years.
There is even a species of bird (Oceanodroma
leucorhoa) that actually has its telomeres
increase in length as they age, but they,
too, are not immortal.
Why and how animals age, it turns out, just
like most things in life, resists such simplistic
explanations.